hello folks
and guten abden from germany
welcome to rational science
uh what do we do here well we do a
little bit of physics
probably the only site that really does
physics
on the internet everybody else does a
lot of math
and irrational explanations we
harp on explanations try to do them
rationally that's what's called rational
science rational physics
and we also do extinction we claim in
this channel
that we are
perhaps the last generation of humans on
earth
not a very pretty theory okay but yeah
we stick by our guns
anyways let's begin with uh extinction
see what we've got
and i guess the question today is will
there be a world war three
okay
um
and if there is a world war three
will it be uh
the last
war or will be or will there be a fourth
world war the fifth world war
or does it end there if there is a world
war three
i mean will the
military throw the bombs and then stop
sign a treaty and continue
or will that be it for all of humanity
so keep that in mind that's gonna be
like the question in the back of
my mind today okay and then we start
here with a little news that came out uh
russia test fires new hypersonic missile
from submarine
and it says the sircon zircon would be
capable of flying at nine times the
speed of sound and have a range of a
thousand kilometers
okay that's uh
that's quite a bit uh
quite a missile you've got there
the ruskies
uh you know and i think uh pretty much
all sides have these kinds of weapons
and the question is if they start using
these weapons you know especially with
uh nukes
at you know in inside them uh will
anyone survive
okay so keep that in mind today it's a
question you have to ponder again if
there is a third world war assuming you
know
uh will anyone survive
will they continue until it's all gone
or
will they manage to stop just before
we screw up the whole planet
and even if they stop
okay even if they stop
you know before they destroy the entire
planet can we recover from such a a
major um
conflagration you know we have this big
fight between the east the west
primarily
the economies of the big countries will
be or the big empires if you want to
call them like that
you know uh will be shattered
so i don't know if we even can recover
even if we stop before this complete
destruction okay
anyways along the same lines here we
have another piece of information
some news some headlines says the u.s
must avoid war with china over taiwan at
all costs
lieutenant colonel daniel davis
who apparently uh
uh did you know was uh working in the
east during a long time
for uh for a long time uh he suggests
that it's not a good idea to go to war
with china no matter what
and says fighting china over taiwan
risks an almost certain military defeat
that's his opinion that's his assessment
america should refuse to be drawn into a
no-win war with beijing
the prevailing mood in washington among
officials and opinion leaders is to
fight if china attempts to recap to
conquer taiwan by force
okay
and the most likely outcome would be a
conventional defeat of our forces in
which china ultimately succeeds
despite our intervention at the cost of
large numbers of our jets being shot
down ships being sunk and thousands of
our service personnel killed okay but
the worst case is a convention that is a
conventional war spirals out of control
and escalates into a nuclear
exchange yeah what's gonna stop uh a
conventional war from
uh turning into a nuclear war
and who are all the parties that are
gonna participate okay
uh so these are things you got to keep
in mind if there is a world war will it
stop at conventional weapons especially
one side is losing being trashed
uh they're probably going to start
pushing those red buttons okay
and it's interesting that he says that
the prevailing mood in washington among
officials and opinion leaders is to
fight
so we got a lot of hawks there and
they're going to be determining assuming
you know there there is a war
they're going to be determining uh the
fate of all of us
interesting huh
someone else determines you your fate
you you plan to go on vacation and these
guys are pressing the red buttons on
each other
uh so your plans are a little shot
so yeah you're going to be learning this
word called taiwan
what is taiwan taiwan is like you know
imagine
california
secedes from the union you know
who was it south carolina in the civil
war was the
first one to secede well here now it's
going to be california for example right
so california secedes from the union
turns out china comes
or russia you know some big empire there
comes uh to its defense it helps
california secede from the union
well what would americans think of that
you know i mean they wouldn't like that
they said what do you mean yeah what's
china and russia got to do here with
california you guys get out of here this
is our problem
and that's more or less a situation with
taiwan taiwan is a renegade province
china says it belongs to it
the world recognizes even the united
states recognizes taiwan as part of
china
in the united nations you know there is
no country called taiwan
in the olympics etc
and
china says uh it wants to reincorporate
it and be able to do what it has to do
with its province it's it's a an
internal problem
and here you have the this treaty where
the united states says there's a taiwan
agreement
and here is uh here's a little bit on
that okay let me put it over here
it says biden china agreed to abide by
what taiwan agreement what the hell is
that
says president joe biden has spoken on
the phone to chinese president okay see
uh biden told reporters on tuesday that
both leaders had agreed to keep to the
taiwan agreement
taiwan agreement what the hell is that
uh an apparent reference to washington's
policy of recognizing beijing's rather
than
beijing rather than taipei right the
capital of taiwan
on the expectation that the future of
taiwan will be determined by peaceful
means
so what if it's not resolved by peaceful
means because the province the governors
of the province don't agree with the
president of china
then we have a problem don't we taiwan's
defense minister said on wednesday china
will be capable of mounting a full-scale
invasion by 2025.
uh what that's four years away
okay adding that relations were at worst
level in more than 40 years
so uh you know china might decide to um
maybe it loses patience
and wants to re-conquer i guess or
what however you want to phrase that
they want their province back
and that might create a problem and that
problem's going to be bigger than
vietnam or afghanistan or any of those
places okay that's gonna be big if that
happens okay
i don't know uh gotta keep that in the
back of your mind
more related to economics which is
my theory about what's gonna happen
remember war is a consequence of
economics
i mean you know
the united states is not there to defend
democracy forget about that that's
wording that politicians use that's just
the phrase a
a way of saying things you know but
what's really there is that you know
it's economics they they have uh
relations with taiwan with people in
taiwan they can go in there do whatever
they want the americans you know they
can go back and forth same time one with
japan and so on and if china takes a
hold of that province
you know a lot of those relations
die immediately because the
shots are called from beijing
so this is a problem and among others
you know something that's currently in
the news is the
uh semiconductors you know one of the
biggest producers of semiconductors in
the world and i mean manufacturers of
semiconductors is taiwan semiconductor i
used to work with these people and
taiwan semiconductor manufactures and
distributes a lot of the
chips
semiconductor chips not potato chips
and uh
the
world right now has uh dearth of chips
and if the chinese take taiwan away it's
just going to get worse
and in fact they would be getting a big
bonus right there just by getting taiwan
semiconductor on their side so there
there's a lot of stuff there that is
beyond just the military capability or
democracy or anything like that there's
economics okay
and so talking about economics here we
have another big news international
business time says biden goes on the
offensive against reckless republicans
and essentially uh biden is
uh upset that
the
as he sees that the gop is not
playing ball they don't want to approve
the budget that he submitted and they go
back and forth do a little horse trading
you know everybody does that in congress
and what they're trying to get is that
budget approved
but apparently if it's not approved by
mid
month
uh the united states will default
which uh
has actually never happened they've
always managed to
to resolve these issues before they
reach that point
but you know a lot of these people just
play politics they just care about
being re-elected
and so when uh you know when someone
comes in there and says look you got to
prove the budget they said well i don't
know if i proved the budget you're going
to look good and i don't like that
because that means i won't be elected
next next time around and so no i'm
going to shoot you down and it's like
nobody cares about the country whether
the country is doing good or bad or
whether that helps the country or not
it's just
politics plain dirty politics of the
worst kind
so
yeah these uh
politicians they play politics and so
you got to find out whether
that's in the best interest of the world
okay because a lot of the world depends
on this big empire called the united
states and here's a few people bickering
over
the budget well to some degree but more
more they're interested in uh
in their own political careers okay
that's what's driving those those
disagreements okay it's along party
lines
okay and who's right who's wrong
doesn't matter really
it matters whether they're gonna approve
the budget
and uh they probably will
they always fight all the way to the
line to the
24th hour of the day you know when it
almost expires and they usually reach an
agreement but it could happen that maybe
they don't reach an agreement okay keep
that in mind
okay and this is the problem uh here's
my take on this uh what's the problem
with the economy well the economy is
that you know we don't do hunter
gathering anymore i don't know if you
see that little red dot there that's
that's approximately how much hunter
gathering we have you know in the world
today okay
uh
agriculture well we have a little more
of that obviously uh but it's a balloon
that's already been popped a long time
ago the advanced nations have only about
one percent of their economies is
agriculture both in terms of labor and
gdp manufacturing a little better
anywhere from 10 to 15 percent in the
advanced nations a little less quite a
bit less in other countries
but what is growing or what has grown
already is uh services services is the
big balloon today
and like i keep saying you know the
services are all abstractions they're
not productive the only way you get
productive is if you turn those services
somehow into stimulating both
agriculture and manufacturing which is
the the which are the two
uh segments that produce something
tangible
other than that services doesn't produce
anything it's just waving of hands you
know and so all we're doing is with
services is moving money around so that
eventually somehow
uh triggers the production of something
tangible in agriculture and
manufacturing
and you can see the advanced nations
have a big problem because what's
what's has grown and is still growing
are services at the expense of
manufacturing agriculture
a lot of manufacturers being automated
you know and uh so that's doesn't make
it any better and you have fewer
companies monopolies big monopolies are
handling the whole situation
on the other hand uh
in service we've got also a big problem
because
manual services you know such as
landscaping construction and those sort
of things
they're they're being
pushed aside also by internet services
what's growing tremendously is internet
services everybody who doesn't have a
job just goes to the internet and does
something tries to get money
and so
internet services are growing and not
only individuals but big corporations
you know amazon and
apple and uh facebook and so on they're
all growing or at least have grown
lately right
and so
what we're growing is a segment that is
truly not productive you could call it
entertainment maybe
that's that's what it is mostly
and yeah there's insurance there's
banking there's other stuff in bitcoin
but primarily it's uh it's these um
line items
that are not productive they don't
produce anything at all all they do is
just produce money
maybe jobs within some of those segments
but what are those jobs producing
nothing absolutely nothing they're just
changing money around that's all they're
doing i seen you you send me some money
and
i use it to
pay the electrician who fix something in
my house you know
and all we're doing is push pulling
pushing money around that's what we're
doing just exchanging hands
okay
another
thing related to
extinction which is
you know whether population is
increasing
related to population basically the fact
that population has now moved from the
country to the city
and uh in and it is in that transition
in every country in the world where
everybody's leaving the farms the farms
are being taken over by big agricultural
corporations
and the
old farmer you know he's coming to the
city and living in the city so people
are being displaced from the country to
the cities more or less like the
enclosure movement in the 16th century
england you know uh they they uh began
to corral the so-called what what until
then had been public lands and you know
the sheep herders and so on they had to
go to the
towns
and they started the people who
corralled the sheep uh those were the
ones who sold the wool
in the world trade that's how that came
up you know
okay anyways uh here we have you can
have technology this fellow says cities
and plenty of babies simultaneously oh
you can uh-huh
all that's required is patriarchy
insist on patriarchy services didn't
kill the family feminism did
love this guy okay uh
so let me let me see if uh if we can um
play some devil's advocacy here okay
here we have
wildlife and uh
analysis by uh people who handle
wildlife said the population suffer
catastrophic collapse
and you go in there and you'll find
several sites and i put a couple of them
here and what they say is that you know
wildlife is disappearing you know they
talk about the
sixth mass extinction
ongoing
even today okay and so the question is
uh was this due to feminism also
is that why all these animals are
disappearing
and for that they say well no this is
encroachment by humans we're encroaching
on their habitats
okay but uh you know again
are we using different standards in
every case why do we say why would we
say that
humans stop reproducing because women
have become feminists but in the case of
animals because of a different reason
altogether i mean we can take any animal
you want you know lions hyenas
uh whatever you want and are we gonna
say that it's because the females
have taken over
okay so
i don't know uh
that's one
way of looking at it let's look at
another way here
okay and that's the one i showed the
other day and that's that uh in the 19th
century
it was the rich people the rich
countries that had babies
not the poor we have this notion in our
minds that's got to do with uh poor
people that have babies
and
that's absolutely not true you know
that's the wrong
assumption
in the 19th century it was the rich
people who had
children and
that stopped in advanced nations again
because people moved to the cities okay
in the cities you have
uh this new situation where uh
it's like an ant hole okay and when you
have this density
uh what we call density independent
birth rates when you have a lot of
density you have density dependent birth
rates and that means that you don't
produce as many children in a dense
population
uh partly because of the crowdedness but
then there's also the issue of social
uh customs
culture changes money is not available
there's many reasons that when people
will flock to the cities and create
these mega cities that we have today 20
million 25 million people in a city uh
they don't produce children there's no
room to have children an apartment
africa as you can see started uh growing
tremendously after 1950 or thereabouts
and today they're still growing not as
not not as
uh fast or at the fast rate as they were
in the 1950s but they're still growing
maybe you know anywhere from three to
six children per family but that's dying
as well as people in africa and
different african countries moved to the
cities okay
once you move to the cities children
stop coming out
that's the way it is
okay uh fellow says
just uh addressing my
uh
dichotomy there testosterone versus
estrogen right
uh come on now bill that's ludicrous uh
those hormones drive differential
physiological development in men and
women because i said women can maybe
come up to par with men in strength
speed etc okay
if uh doesn't agree yeah it says and
even if you made everything else equal
men would still have a significant
advantage
um
simply uh owing to more robust bodies
and more muscle mass
aha uh if we started injecting women
with testosterone from early age they
might catch up
okay uh i don't know uh let's find out
let's find out that's true okay uh
uh so let i'm gonna ask him some
questions i'm saying are there women who
are stronger than men
are there women who are faster than men
and are there women who can beat men up
you know is
is this
uh out of the ordinary or is this alive
today this notion that you know there
are women who are big women fast women
you know uh good wrestling women or
women who are very well trained at uh
martial arts or whatever
or or is are those
things that only men have let me see if
i'm going out of focus here
uh or are those things that are unique
to men strength speed etc
okay
another fellow also along the same lines
says to win wars you must take the
brutal step kill the man and rape the
women
i'm wondering what century this fellow
is uh living in uh maybe he's uh
thinking of attila the hun or genghis
khan or suleiman the magnificent one of
those fellas the vikings
uh i don't know uh
i think this fellow is in the wrong
century okay
and let me uh
let me
show you something here because it's i
think it's the same father who put in
there says uh the average man could
easily defeat ronda rousey in combat
okay and rhonda is that little girl
there among all those men she was at uh
i
think paris or whatever with all these
actors and so on
i'm almost sure in fact i i would be
willing to bet
a beer on it right that she could beat
each one of those men individually at a
one-to-one duel okay inside the ring
and uh you can say those are average men
i'm sure i can take any fella from the
street i don't care how big he is he
could be 220 pounds
and she would run circles around and get
him by the legs throw him down and then
you know put a leg scissor around his
neck
make it maybe break every bone in his
body and then laugh at him when she
comes out of there
you know i mean to think that he thinks
that
that rhonda is is just a little girl
there you know uh
playing footsie
uh i'm sure that if i put him against
ronda
i i think we all know who would win
there okay
yeah
she's a professional um
uh fighter okay she's trained to do
karate judo wrestling she does that
every day she's been doing that since
she was a kid and you think you're just
gonna step in the ring and and slap her
around silly
boy some people really have their feet
off the ground that's what i think okay
you got to come back to earth fella
okay let me show you something else here
okay have you ever seen this
these are women okay
and uh
since about 1977
women bodybuilding has taken off lots of
women entering that field they're
entering what because they want to look
good now they're entering because of
money again there are no jobs out there
so they enter the field of entertainment
and part of that entertainment is uh
running for contests you know beauty
contests on the one hand muscle contests
on the other and women are entering
there okay
now these are not girls that you may
want to date
they're a little grotesque at least for
my taste
but uh this is reality this is not
photoshopped okay by by the way just in
case okay these women are not
photoshopped these women exist out there
and you say well are they women
they don't they certainly don't look
like women do they okay not the ordinary
women we're used to
but this is reality guys i mean 100
years ago you wouldn't find something
like this okay
something has changed
and so you got to get used to the fact
that women are coming up the ranks in
many ways
among them
in uh strength might
wrestling uh
fast running i i was talking about the
record held by this um
[Music]
griffith uh griffith joyner i think um
she's got the record she she ran it
quite fast
uh 10 point something i think 10.3 i'm
sure that she could beat the hell out of
a lot of men in running
and so the question is you know are you
gonna say uh that those women eventually
will not catch up with men
why not they've caught up quite fast to
us in just 40 years why can't they
continue
and again if you look at the hyena world
you know the female hyenas are bigger
than the males they run the show
and a male hyena
cannot fight a female especially the
the uh head of the clan
there's no way the female hyena will
beat the crap out of the male
and so
you know are you gonna say well he's got
testosterone she's got estrogen you know
but it looks like
it didn't doesn't matter in that world
does it okay
and here let me show you
along those lines
here you have
a lion right
well no that's like the article says
it's not a lion king it's a lion queen
okay that's a female lion that's got a
mane which is
usually reserved for
male lions
and they found in both botswana uh a few
years ago um
five of these
in a clan
and they all had means
okay and uh
the theory is that they are have a
little more testosterone than usual they
do behave like females to some degree
but one of them even mounted another
female
okay
so we've got something going on in this
world today
okay this is this not this is not
something that existed in the days of
the romans when you know they brought
lions into the
uh
coliseum this is something new
and this is something new because
the population of lions has decreased
significantly they were like 150
000 only 50 years ago now there's only
35 000
and so now there's inbreeding there's uh
fewer uh you know the gene pool is much
smaller
and so you know i'm i'm sure that this
has
something to do with genetics okay
and here you see uh an analysis by
people who studied this okay
and here you'll see it says until now
reports of such main lionesses have been
extremely rare and largely anecdotal a
likely explanation is an increased level
of what testosterone as these lionesses
mature well i don't know about mature i
think it's got to do with not with
whether they have matured it's got to do
with the fact that these lionesses
uh are the product of inbreeding okay
says there must be a genetic component
in this population underlying the
phenomena yeah i agree well some of the
main linuses were observed mating none
of them became pregnant
suggesting they are infertile a known
consequence of high levels of androgens
such as testosterone and females yeah
what they're missing is the fact that uh
they're probably inferno because they
you know they're the product again of uh
inbreeding okay it never appeared to
them that this could be a product in
bree
i don't think this is anything to be
concerned about says one of the
researchers there although the females
are apparently infertile they otherwise
appear to be living long healthy lives
totally irrelevant to the issue he
hasn't discovered the reason that these
animals have manes
and from a conservative perspective
there is nothing to suggest the pattern
is increasing or will ever be anything
more than a rare local phenomenon
totally mistaken again these people that
have no clue whatsoever studying these
animals could the masculine lies females
in fact be a boon to the pride when it
comes to competing with other prides
again irrelevant questions that these
people ask
they don't even know what the issues are
or what they should be investigating
they should really figure out why
these animals are coming out now it
means
and i'm telling you it's got to do with
genetics like they say
but they're missing the point the point
is that we have fewer and fewer
lions in the world today
and you know at some point it's going to
be sister with sister
or and you know lying with lion
brother with brother
so you know i don't know uh
we have the wrong people doing research
out there they have no clue whatsoever
what's going on around them
and yeah if we have a problem with
genetics and if we add to that the fact
that you know we if for humans right we
have a problem where there is no genetic
diversity among the human race we're now
marrying sisters and brothers today
from a genetic standpoint and on top of
that you have this cultural change where
women are going into what into boxing
and kickboxing and running and
sports and entertainment
uh you know put it all together is this
world gonna last another billion years
we're never gonna die
humans
i don't know
my intuition says something is different
and
fatal
okay something is nearing the end of the
line
okay and here you see another example of
the siamese fruits and siamese
veggies even the vegetables and the
fruits
are coming out
with
with genetic problems
why because we've been inbreeding them
for a long time i mean grapes you know
how we grow grapes today did we put a
seed in the ground is that the way we do
it today like in the old days like
mother nature used to do it absolutely
not what we're doing is
uh we're cutting a branch from another
vine and planting it we're cloning them
we're cloning grapes we're doing a lot
of that with these uh
fruits and veggies
and you can pick up alt and pick out
almost any fruit or veggie that is out
there that we regularly eat and you'll
find a case of siamese twins
and you're saying is is this always been
the case
or is this something new is it that some
of these fruits are reaching the end of
the line because we are artificially
uh
selecting them
like we we don't like watermelons with a
lot of seeds so we select them in such a
way that eventually is a seedless
uh watermelon or its seeds are no good
even though it's got many of these
little seeds are they're not any good
for planting okay
and
we see this with lots of fruits and lots
of veggies where they try to get rid of
the
the unwanted part which is the seed
because you know you don't like to
crunch seed so
if you want to sell it and you want to
beat your competitor well you
raise some fruit or some veggie that
does not have seeds
okay and we're doing this to the plants
where we're killing these plants in our
own way
okay aside from the fact that they've
been around for a long time and also you
know they lost their genetic diversity
so what you're seeing is not only humans
that have lost their genetic diversity
animals which have lost their genetic
diversity and growing you know females
growing mains you have
also animals with with two heads you'll
see
some cases today quite a few cases
really of siamese twins and now you see
veggies and fruits as well
you think this has always happened
well i can tell you for sure at least
one case that it has that
shows at least that it has not always
been the case
in the case of
peaches
peaches about two thousand three
thousand years ago were like berries
that's how big they were
and humans uh artificially selected them
and today you have the peach that is you
know maybe baseball
size okay
or tennis ball size
and we helped that
fruit grow over the years over the
centuries over the millennia
and now they're bigger
but you know in some of my trees
i found that i had at least one tree had
five of these siamese
uh peaches
five of them and that's when i started
looking at the fact that a lot of fruits
are having you know
these problems these genetic problems as
i see it and so yeah when they were
little berries i doubt very much there
was any siamese twin there it's when we
grew them we selected them we wiped out
their overall genetic uh diversity and
yeah now we start seeing these problems
but we're not aware of that everybody
looks at these and says oh how
interesting we had a siamese pear or
whatever
i think it's a little more than that
okay especially when you see it across
the board
veggies and fruits what you're eating is
a
is a unhealthy fruit
it's like saying that you know uh if you
had a monster that ate humans well
what kind of you know maybe a cyclops
would you like to eat a
healthy human or would you want to eat a
human with two heads
[Laughter]
something's wrong without you but
okay
okay father says no way humanity will
last forever
well that's a great statement but uh we
got a problem because you haven't told
us why you think uh humanity will last
forever
uh it won't last forever i mean why
won't you what's gonna kill us
if you take that to some people the
people say well we're smart we can see
things in advance we can see 4c events
we have the technology we have the
knowledge we can address the problem
right
and so humans will live forever
and he says they won't but we need a
reason
we need a theory
a mechanism what will kill humans what
and more important than that
what will he kill humans that humans can
do nothing about
for which intelligence
and technology and
the ability to foresee events has no way
of addressing
that's the question because then you
have found what will kill humans okay
but to say humans will not live forever
you know it's just a gas it's a
it's a shot in the uh in the air and you
haven't told us anything you haven't
told us why that is not why that's the
case okay
okay uh continuing here
this comes from the wikipedia phil says
extinction of humans and he goes out
there and uh just recites essentially uh
you know just copied and pasted overall
probability 19 molecular nanotechnology
weapons five percent these are all these
uh reasons that
humans might become extinct okay these
are percentages i'm not sure what the
percentages have anything to do with
extinction one is a qualitative the
other one is a quantitative
assessment okay
but it's got all these things what you
won't find in there is food
you won't find economic collapse
okay
and uh
so the question is are any of these even
in the ballpark well the only one i
would give is wars okay but they only
gave four percent to wars okay four
percent that's that's the only
probability that a war might come i
think there's a much bigger probability
of war but uh more important than that
is why will there be a war
if there is a war well if there is a war
it's because of economics
it's because of resources a fight for
the resources that's what it's all about
so it all comes back to economics
okay so
i don't think you can avoid economics no
matter what
says money is not trust trust is what
makes money work
well yeah i mean it's like without the
trust there is no money okay it's like
if you don't trust the other guy you
want to accept money
and
trust is very important in the asphalt
jungle
okay especially if you know a little bit
about the green or the
woody uh
jungle you know i mean
the one that wild animals live in
there if you trust
that's the end of you
i don't think there's a buffalo or a
wildebeest that trusts the lion
i don't think there's a zebra that
trusts uh hyena pack of hyenas
uh
there is no trust in the wild
and
you know the day money disappears that
we have no longer trusted money you had
better not trust any kind of trade
because it's going to be like the wild
animals you're going to be
you know trading your life
okay so
yeah
money is trust
okay and again uh right now we only
think of trust in terms of do i trust
that guy you know will he deliver the
goods
uh when you're in the asphalt jungle
okay and no money it's gonna be a little
worse than that that's when trust
becomes a lot more important issue
especially you you got to talk about
money and again that's why there won't
be any money because there won't be any
trust
okay so
i don't know a lot of people have to
think about these things a little more
in depth okay
uh phil says regarding uh the definition
of life you know how do we define life
alive a natural object that moves
against the path of least resistance
primarily gravity and so the foul says
is a solar flare alive okay
well
a solar flare is not an object and the
definition says clearly object
so uh
that's elementary my dear watson okay
uh solar flare what is it a sudden flash
of increased brightness
none of those words represent a fake
physical object
okay so yeah you have to have an object
to talk about live
or living alive or living okay
so uh yeah you you gotta start there if
you're gonna criticize the definition
make sure that you have an object to
begin with otherwise you know you're
attacking a straw man
okay uh here's a
listing of
words that maybe this gentleman should
come to grips with
in physics we need these words we need
to
recognize them as non-objects you can't
use any of these words as objects
he mentioned there uh what a solar flare
yeah not an object and again it's people
who introduce ordinary speech into
physics but here are other words that
follow along those same lines okay first
one is plasma plasma is not an object
plasma is a process what process
ionization of an atom okay or several
atoms electricity is not an object
either electricity is a process
uh under the rope model torsion of
merged electron shells and there you see
it on the far right
uh fire is not an object okay so you
can't say oh fire goes upwards up the
walls yeah it goes against gravity but
fire is not an object so you can't say
that is fire alive no fire is a process
it's a process of combustion what is
combustion oxidation of some kind of
substance okay
uh electromagnetic wave is there such an
object as that absolutely not what
you're staring at there are uh vectors
okay and vectors uh are little arrows
they
uh represent magnitude and direction
with and what you're staring at there is
the movement of these vertical
magnitudes of these uh magnitudes and
directions so it's a very scary because
they think that's a physical object
simply because they put all these arrows
there to represent it and they put them
in motion to make things worse no a wave
is not a physical object the wave is
the the object is the flag
wave is what it does object is the water
wave is what it does and in the case
here uh you would think that uh what is
waving is what it whatever object uh
is uh underlying light so whatever light
is that's what's waving in the best of
cases and what you got to do is identify
the object that mediates light that's
how simple it is
okay
vortex is not an object what is a
tornado is a tornado an object
absolutely not what threw your house
down was air
okay the object is called air you can
call it gas molecules but never vortex
vortex is what air does
okay so a tornado is what air does or or
any board to any world of that sword you
gotta identify the object that's the
point okay you need to find out what
object is twirling
okay
regarding covid someone says oh no you
took the experimental jab now you're a
guinea pig
uh
yeah
maybe i'm a guinea pig
i did it because i plan to do some
traveling hopefully towards the end of
the year and so you know you got the
holidays coming up
and so
uh
i don't want the hassle at the airports
and there's big hassle still today
hopefully all that dies by next year
okay but right now it's still a big
issue you got to get the pcr test if you
want to travel when you leave when you
arrive
and if you're
and now in fact a lot of the airlines
are probably going to request or demand
that people be vaccinated and so i don't
want the hassle that's what it's all
about of course if you're not traveling
and maybe you don't even work with
people or work at all then you're not
concerned okay
but you're in a different situation have
people who work with lots of people out
there
cashiers or whatever and they don't they
don't want to be exposed to so many
people and they
want to take it on the safe side and
they say i'm going to get a vaccine
because i might catch this this virus
whether they the virus is there or not
is irrelevant the point is you know if
you're if you're
out there with lots of people you don't
want to take the risk because in fact
you don't know you're not a doctor even
if you were a doctor you probably don't
know
if there's a virus or not all you do is
guess like anybody else whether you
guess left or get guessed right it
doesn't really matter because if you're
with a lot of people you want to be on
the safe side you say well i'm not going
to even risk it my my
uh health
and other people say well i'm not going
to get a vaccine because it's government
imposed on me
well you know i'm sure just about
everybody on planet earth has been
vaccinated at least once
against something you know when you go
to school especially in in the west you
know in advanced nations when you go to
school you get vaccinated
government mandated you know uh you
gotta have your vaccine etc etc etc very
few people can escape it maybe for
religious reasons but in general you
know just about everybody gets
vaccinated against something you know
and so the question is that's mandated
that's government you're vaccinated
probably
uh against something out there because
you went to school
and now you're gonna protest because the
government is
uh forcing a backs down your you know up
your arm a jab up your arm
you know think about that uh why didn't
you protest when when you went to school
you probably have iraq seen in you i'm
almost sure
okay uh another follow the same thing it
is the idiots who get backs
that become perpetually sick until they
un until their untimely death
uh yeah again i got a vaccine only
because uh
of traveling uh i don't care either way
um you know
for me it's an and not a non-issue okay
that's what it is not an issue all
together
and here uh final one on on vaccines
here the fell says in 2020 they
demonstrated their biotech power by
infecting the world with virus outbreak
talking about china weak but enough to
destroy a significant part of the
western economy aha who knows what they
have in those laboratories in wuhan
and now probably a cyber attack against
facebook he had one the other day right
facebook had some kind of problem and
this all says it's the chinese who are
doing all this they're doing the vaccine
they're doing facebook they're doing all
these nasty things
of course you can get a lot of people
who will say well it's the
rich people in the united states who are
doing all this and they created the
buyers and took it to wuhan
and again do we have any evidence of any
of this
you know
i mean there's no way you're ever going
to get evidence for any of that even the
governments they have an interest in
saying oh it was the other side
it was the other gang that did this
and you go to the other gang and they
say oh no it was that gang that did it
and
i know for sure i know that take this
for a fact okay you heard it here first
it was canada
that
created this vaccine okay the vax this
covid thing
they created the whole works
and you might disagree with me you might
think it was the french you know you got
your opinion i got mine okay
so that's about as good as it gets with
kobe then and the origin of coldwood
okay let's get on to
do some physics here
uh we were talking about speed the other
day
and distance and the question is
is there a difference between
speed and velocity you know we talk
about the speed of light and the
velocity of light which is true i mean
is there a difference
can we use those terms interchangeably
okay
and so in order to get to the bottom of
it we got to go back to almost the 17th
century pretty much there why because
that's when a revolution occurred known
as the scientific revolution
and you had people of the caliber of
newton and leibniz in germany leibniz uh
newton in england
and they invented the calculus and
before they could invent the calculus
they had to have a reason for inventing
it and so they were developing some math
some new math
in those days
french and the
british and the germans they were all
trying to
solve some problems related to motion
and so they started investigating these
things from a mathematical point of view
and they came up with some
fancy things that today would have
garnered them on nobel prize okay
and so what is uh velocity well here you
have a uh an idea here we have mr
leibniz and mr newton
they were contemporaries
and um
what is velocity well in order to get to
velocity uh really instantaneous
velocity it's better to say that whole
phrase instantaneous velocity the whole
term okay
because it's different than average
velocity okay
and i'm not here to uh teach math
we don't do math here i just want to
because some people are going to say
bill i thought you didn't do math and
you're doing math no no we're not going
to do math okay but i'm going to show
you is the procedure that these people
followed and why we ended up with
mathematical physics today so-called
physic you know it's mathematical
with quotations something called physics
right and it comes from this they were
trying to solve some problems what were
they trying to solve well they were
trying to figure out among other things
you know instantaneous velocity
and what was that well they said let's
start with uh average velocity and so
you take that curve there the black one
that's in the center
which is a curve like an s
and that curve if you chop off two
points on it right one on the bottom one
arbitrarily right you just chop it at
one point and another point and you draw
that blue line between them right
straight line
well you can calculate uh uh you know
the starting point which you can say
it's uh that's in the initial position
of whatever is moving okay at certain
time
and then you end up at another position
at a different time
and you have to take that straight line
okay
and what you do is subtract uh the
position the ending position
uh you subtract the beginning position
you take the ending time you subtract
the beginning time
and you do a division you get the
average velocity
very simple stuff really okay
okay so that's more or less how they
started and from there they moved on to
trying to figure out the instantaneous
velocity what the hell was that well
that was a given point on the curve okay
and here i uh
arbitrarily selected a point okay
and you got to think of this as
putting a circle
that begins and it ends in that point on
that point okay
you draw the
radius
of that circle from that point to the to
the center of the circle
and uh you put a tangent tangent is
perpendicular
to that radius okay
and that tangent okay that's going to be
the slope of that curve
and you can do the same thing we did
just now you take the beginning point
the ending point subtract one from the
other you calculate
that value right
and what you do is take what is known as
the limit okay the limit
of that
product that you just had there what are
we talking about we're saying that if
you move along that tangent where you
see the purple
tangent
the x on the right hand side and the t
on the right hand side
if you move along that t downwards to
the point
the closer you get to the point
the more you approximate right
the instantaneous velocity okay it's
known as taking the limit
of t as approaches zero of the
difference imposition over the
difference in time
that's conceptually what these people
were doing
okay so that was the velocity okay so
velocity is a calculation
and it's already got some problems there
and let me tell you what the problems
are the first one is that there is no
such thing as position in mathematics
in the religion of mathematics
especially mathematical physics okay
there's no such thing as position
because when someone says position
everybody thinks
in you know a static concept like
location
like you're standing still i'm a
disposition
and that's not the concept at all
mathematics has no use for static
concepts
okay mathematics are all dynamic
concepts deals only with adverbs no
adjectives okay and what are we saying
we're saying that you need two
coordinates to get
to that position
so you have one trace and another trace
you know
a
pair there of traces
and you end at a position
that's what a position is in mathematics
it's a um
a pair of uh numbers
okay and so that's one position the
other one is another position how do you
locate the position with two or maybe
even three coordinates what's a
coordinate it's an itinerary it's not a
line
you see a line that's what they put but
what you're looking at is an itinerary
they're counting the paces that the
pirate has to take to reach the treasure
chest
okay so both position and coordinates
and vectors and dimensions they're all
the same thing
they're all itineraries
there is no such thing as distance in
mathematics okay
distance is distance traveled
distance is not separation gap
okay
chasm that's not what distance is
distance is unrolling the front of your
measuring tape
it's a dynamic concept it's distance
traveled displacement
okay so none of the concepts of
mathematics
are static concepts okay and velocity is
is a weird one because
especially instantaneous velocity why
because you're looking at a point
and you're looking at one cross section
of time
but there is no such monster as a cross
section of time in mathematics because
time
involves at least two frames of the
movie
if you talk about one second you've
already covered two two frames at least
a starting point and an ending point
there's no such thing as one frame time
which is what they're trying to do with
velocity they're trying to calculate the
value when you reach uh when you
approach zero zero time but you never
you never get to zero time you only
approach it so that you can calculate
and find out what the velocity is
uh the value that you want to calculate
that's gonna be the velocity at that
point but you never get there because if
you got there you got zero and you can't
divide by zero which is time
uh final minus time initial you can't
have zero
otherwise you're dividing by zero and
that gives you at infinity according to
the mathematicians
okay so you can't do that
so you approach zero you never get there
there is no such thing as a static time
static position
or static uh separation like uh distance
true distance physical distance no such
monster in mathematics mathematics
everything is motion
and you have to get that through your
thick skull right off the bat otherwise
you're you're going to be lost when you
try to give a physical interpretation
okay
okay
here we have uh
another uh version of this so that we
can compare velocity against speed what
is the difference okay let me put this
over here
instantaneous velocity which we just
mentioned rate of change of position
with respect to time what was position
it was a dynamic concept okay because
they're talking about rate of change of
position but each position requires two
or three coordinates to get or you can
even do it with one i guess you know uh
you're looking at motion for each
position and they're gonna they're gonna
look at these two positions
of something that moved okay
and how much time it took okay so
they've got to look at the rate of
change of position with respect to time
what is instantaneous
well there there we write the problem
for sure it says
instant value of time t
no such monster in in
in physics you can't have instant time
a cross section of time you can't have a
single frame of time time requires at
least two frames conceptually that's why
you have to define these terms something
the mathematicians never did who was it
uh newton who used time quite a bit and
then he says oh by the way
i don't define time space motion etc
because we all know what it is that's
what he says in his skull
the beginning of his
uh seminal book okay
principia uh
okay so what is speed well speed is the
same thing as velocity
but without the direction okay so
distance first distance traversed or
traveled
it's that distance
it's the unrolling of the measuring tape
you've got some motion of the end of the
tape you're counting meters feet
whatever five feet
what you did is take the standard the
foot
and you put five of those
okay that's what distance is in
mathematics the distance is not empty
space between the table and the chair
distance is how many feet are there
between this table and the chair
its distance traveled okay or traversed
speed what is it time rate of
displacement you have to have this
placement for you to use the word speed
in mathematics and what is displacement
is it distance
yeah in mathematics it is because
displacement and distance traveled is
the same thing
they don't have distance they don't have
just qualitative separation gap
okay
they don't have distance in mathematics
no such thing as a static concept in
mathematics okay
so what is velocity well velocity is
speed plus direction you take direction
away you have speed
okay we got that
in general okay
uh you can review the tape later
rewind the tape and see it again if you
haven't caught up okay let me continue
then um
so here is uh so
what do we have speed of light or
velocity of light
well let's find out here we have ah come
on
give me a second here fellow overboard
sometimes i have this it falls on the
other side with us okay here it is so
what is the speed of light three hundred
thousand kilometers per second
and where's the velocity of light well
it's also three hundred thousand
kilometers per second
looks like uh
they're equal right
especially when uh they say that light
travels at a constant speed or velocity
if it travels at a constant pace
constant rate
never changes okay or at least in a
vacuum right
then the the
velocity and the speed should be the
same right
let's find out
first of all here let's plot it okay
there you see the speed of light and it
should be a straight line right
so if it's speed or velocity really
there should be no difference between
those two here
okay
and um so we look up to see what uh
whether
it's true that it's a constant right and
these are some uh testimonies out there
from people from um
uh i guess from
uh reliable sources more or less okay
and they all say the same thing
what does the american museum natural
history talking about einstein and all
these other people they said the speed
of light is constant and does not depend
on the speed of the light source that
essentially comes from mr einstein who
more or less
uh
proved that to his buddies the
mathematicians okay um another site the
physics fact riverside
the speed of light in vacuum is exactly
blah blah 300 000
kilometers per second okay is c a
constant yes
no doubt about it in their minds okay
the speed of light in a vacuum commonly
denoted c little c right is a universal
physical what constant
okay so we got it right
little c is a constant the velocity of
light the speed of light is a constant
out there
in the vacuum in in outer space okay
and um
and yeah values three hundred thousand
kilometers per second more or less
rounding off is 299
something
okay
so we got that straight uh
light travels at a constant speed in the
vacuum
straight forward
but we got a major problem there major
major problem okay
and here's the problem
okay here we have mr einstein says that
light curves in outer space when it uh
encounters mass
and we have masses all over the place
because even one
hydrogen atom is mass
has mass
and weighs down space time and if
one atom of hydrogen weighs down
space-time
light a little photon that goes around
it
is uh curved in its
um in its uh trajectory
it's deflected from a straight line path
from a rectilinear path as you see there
it's curving around okay this comes from
nasa
okay and so
what happened when light is bent
uh curb warp deflected however you want
to say it by gravity in other words
gravity
bends space time and here you have that
little photon or maybe it's a wave i
don't know you tell me
and it goes around
well
like it says there when speed of an
object is changing it has an
acceleration
i don't know if that sank in but let me
just clarify it in case it didn't
i thought we just said that light
travels at a constant speed
300 000 kilometers per second
in outer space in the vacuum
and now we're saying that when
light reaches the sun
like here's uh proof evidence that
people like to have okay here it is
mr arthur eddington 1919 he proved to
the world that einstein was great why
because he was able to show that
light from a star behind the sun
curves around
the sun and reaches our eye
okay that's what he proved with his
camera okay they went out into the
middle of the ocean and we were able to
film this during an eclipse
and so the issue here is that uh and
this is one of the proofs of one of the
major proofs in fact the first proof of
general relativity by the way okay but
uh what we're seeing here is that if
light travels at a constant speed it
travels at 300 000 kilometers per second
rounding off right
and now we're going to force that photon
or that wave to curve
well now it's going to have to
accelerate just like it says there when
the speed of an object is changing it
has an acceleration
okay and it's going to change whenever
it encounters an object it's moving
around it's curving it's no longer going
straight
okay i hope people are following me
okay
so yeah we have a problem because now we
have light traveling at not only
different speeds but a faster speed than
light
i thought light traveled at a constant
speed in the vacuum and now we're saying
now einstein is saying well by the way
you know it does curve around and when
it curves around we have acceleration
so if light the little photon
accelerated
it's now traveling at 301
k
kilometers per second or maybe 305 maybe
310 who knows
so uh
why is this somewhat of a problem well
here you see it uh mr einstein he put in
his equation 1915
and you can see on the right hand side
there you see a little c there that i
circled
and he treated that as a constant
but he should have known like all
mathematicians should have known that
that little c is not a constant
especially if he's going to talk about
warp space what time
or space time
okay now you got a curve now you got an
acceleration okay and you see it there
on the bottom so
we have a problem between speed and
velocity because speed is okay because
if speed is without a direction so you
say the speed of light is 300 000
kilometers per second okay granted how
about velocity well the velocity now
changed the velocity of light because if
it's going to go through a curve the
thing accelerated
and if we do what we did at the
beginning and calculate the
instantaneous velocity
we should have a value
greater than 300 000 kilometers per
second little c so we have a
contradiction
and that's not the only contradiction
let me give you another one just there
and it's got to do with that big g on
the right upper right hand corner you
see that big g
eight pi
big g that big g stands for the
gravitational constant
that was determined by this gentleman
his name was uh cavendish henry
cavendish
okay
with his torsion balance
okay he was he tried to determine he
apparently succeeded in determining the
value of g a lot of people question that
but well in general this is what is used
today torsion balance is to this day
used to determine the value of g
and you say well what's the problem
well the problem is that um
mr einstein made it very clear
absolutely very clear that
in general relativity you can only apply
it out there
in the macro world
you cannot apply it to this you know a
pencil or a pen falling to earth
you cannot use his equations here at
this level
you're talking about big distances big
masses
that's how his equation works the
equation does not work at this level
there is no curvature here to such a
degree that would force
this you know the space time i mean
what's warping the space here in such a
way that this falls to the ground
no way
and so einstein said look this equation
is we're out there it's not for the
micro world microbull meaning anything
within earth
like a pencil falling to the ground
that's why that's trying to who treats
that well it's uh quantum mechanics that
tries to treat uh deal with
uh quantum with gravity at this level
out there you can use einstein's
equation
but the gravitational constant was
determined down here by mr cavendish in
his torsion balance and it's still to
this they determine here on earth with
the torsion balance
so we have this torsion balance
determined g here in our micro world
and einstein takes that little that g
that big g and
uses it to calculate something out there
in the middle of a space
at the solar system uh
star galactic levels
we got a little problem there because uh
can we be sure that he can use that as a
constant
so we have problem with those two
constant with big g and little c
okay little c cannot be a constant in
warp space and big g cannot be used out
there because it's determined down here
okay i hope i made my point there
we got a problem with uh with this with
einstein's reasoning and not only
einstein's all these mathematicians they
they should be aware of this they're not
that stupid they should be aware that
you can't use big g
and c just just to do your calculation
say oh here here's the solution okay
uh we got a problem with that because
uh
you know because of what i just said you
can't use the little c as a constant in
curved space and you can't use g out
there in the macro world because it's
determined in the microworld
okay so um
let me show you this so what's the issue
where does all this problem come from it
comes from
the fact that we started
on the wrong foot in the 17th century
where people like leibniz and newton
even before them galileo and others you
know
what happened is people
took us on the wrong path they said
science
physics
is about math
and experiments
and so they said how do you confirm the
equation well you confirm it with an
experiment
well you can confirm any an equation
because what you do is measure during an
experiment and you turn that measurement
into some kind of equation
that is what a description
of what happened
we still don't have an explanation
we don't have a mechanism because for
mechanisms and explanations you need
objects you have to make a movie of
what's happened
and they can't do that because they
can't see or touch the invisible
entities mother nature uses to do
gravity
magnetism etc
okay so this is where the problem is and
so because they could not solve
the real problems of physics
the mechanisms with their equations
they took science along the direction
of mathematics
and they said well science is
uh doing experiments measuring and
putting out equations
and so today everybody you know for 400
years has been repeating that saying
that
physics and science is all about
measurement and equations
and obviously
observation of an experiment
when we don't have any explanations for
how this universe runs
you won't find a rational explanation
out there okay and so this is where it
starts uh what is physics about
here we have some definitions that we
have today
this is what we ended up with after what
about 400 years now if not a little more
physics the branch of science concerned
with the nature and properties of matter
and
what is that
energy
what the hell is
i mean i don't know what physics is
until i know what energy is is that what
they're saying i need to know what this
fancy word energy
is in order to understand what physics
is all about
okay the subject matter of physics
includes mechanics okay hopefully you
know uh we want to see mechanics okay
some kind of mechanism so we need to
figure out what
mechanism what a mechanism is
can we do mechanisms with equations with
variables with numbers or do we need
physical objects to do mechanism to show
someone what the mechanism of something
is
okay this is the the issue
okay and that's interesting to say the
structure of atoms and mathematics
doesn't deal with structure at all in
fact mathematics doesn't care like uh
what the structure of the atom is
because they're just going to describe
motion they're not going to deal with
structure they're going to deal with the
only thing mathematics deals with
which is
motion
how something moves not what it is
math does not deal with structure and
they say energy we'll find out in a
minute what energy is hopefully
hopefully we'll get to know what physics
is about because we can't know what
physics is about until we know what
energy is about okay or what it is
and uh that was from the extra
dictionary wikipedia says physics is the
natural science that studies now in
science we don't study anyone can study
and be ignorant
uh in science we're not ignorant in
science we have to produce a
theory
okay an explanation for something if you
just studied and don't have an
explanation you're not a scientist so no
physics science they're not about
studying
anybody can study
and get a zero on the test
so studies matter okay it's fundamental
constituents okay i don't think that's
the case because they don't care what
those constituents are they don't deal
with objects at all
it's motion and behavior yeah they deal
with that okay through space and time
time what do you mean through time
is time a medium like an ocean is that
what time is like air
you move through time
you move through space also space is
nothing how can you move through nothing
i mean i'm
i think it's easy to move through
nothing try to move us through something
you know through
to water or air but to move through
nothing i don't know how you can do that
okay especially if you haven't defined
what nothing is
and the related what entities entities
of energy
energy is an entity
force
force is also an entity
what kind of entities are these
see they they're refining these these
words they're turning these concepts
into physical objects
making them concrete okay so they're
solid
okay here we have uh
a book i've got here okay and uh these
are the topics that uh are
taught to people who go to high school
somewhere in college as well this is
from a college level book and you can
see what kind of subjects they teach you
know people who
start
physics for the first time
and they start out by going over the uh
geometry you know some of the history of
how we ended up like this
and they start with the motions of the
earth measurement of time etc and they
end up their number nine page 74 they
start at mechanics
okay mechanics finally we get to
mechanics okay hopefully that's what
physics is about mechanics above all
right and they're going to do mechanics
good great i love it let's see what
they've got
well um it turns out that when you go in
there and look these are they have a
bunch of equations
and you say well hold it is that
mechanics
is mechanics about what speed distance
divided by time which we just covered a
minute ago angular speed number of
rotations per time velocity equal to
speed plus direction and displacement
is this mechanics
this sounds like math to me not
mechanics
mechanics is you know like
a car
how it works
how it runs give me the theory of why it
moves
that's mechanics how i pull the box up
through a pulley now that's mechanics
how uh ball rolls down the inclined
plane why it falls down in other words
what's drawing it down but to calculate
measure and say what's the speed of the
ball is that mechanics
okay so
you can see how the mathematicians took
it all along their specialty they said
ah we're going to do physics in this
direction we're going to do math
and they forget about the explanations
in fact they have no explanations even
to this day for anything for any
invisible intangible
object or mechanism that mother nature
has out there they have no explanations
whatsoever why because they never
identified the invisible intangible
objects mother nature uses
okay so this is the problem
and regarding that famous word energy
fortunately we have here so that we
don't lose track of what energy is we
have mr feynman tell us finally you know
what energy is and what does he say
he says in one of his lectures he says
it is important to realize that in
physics today we have no knowledge of
what energy is
so what is physics about energy and what
is energy we don't know what it is so we
don't know what physics is about but we
do mechanics and what kind of mechanics
do we do well we do equations
and i don't want to know equations i
want to know the mechanism i thought
that's what mechanics was about
you know and when you go there they say
no no we do equations here we don't do
mechanics we
have these equations about speed and
velocity and about how fast uh
light goes
but we have no mechanics why don't you
have any mechanics well because they
have no idea
what
entity underlies light
they've never
figured out what light is
the structure the architecture of what's
underlying
light
and so they modeled it with a bunch of
particles they modeled it with waves
transverse waves first they had
longitudinal waves
and they ended up with this notion of
what light is and they say well let is
something that vibrates up and down
okay it goes up and down right
yeah but we muddled it with little
particles going straight because light
goes straight as newton said
and light also vibrates up and down like
huygens said
and how do you get something that
goes up and down at the same time that
it goes straight
well the solution came in the 21st
century it's known as a rope
and you can see the bumps the goosebumps
okay when this torx along a straight
entity
meaning really a tight tense
entity
and so now yes we can unify
the goosebumps with something that is
straight taught in this case okay a rope
does mimic both
properties okay something that a
[Music]
particles cannot simulate
anything related to waves and waves
certainly do not behave anywhere like
particles especially if the wave is
going up and down like a standing wave
is the particle going up and particle
going down is that what's happening to
the particle that constitutes the wave
is that what we're saying
so what's taking the particle up what's
taking the particle down
and yeah these are the questions they
never answer they just say oh we just do
math
we we describe with equations
and that's what we have today
i'm going to continue this this line of
questioning the
not only the establishment but we're
going to question the
foundations of physics here okay in the
next few weeks okay
so tune in
i'll be talking about the foundations of
physics
okay let's get on with some of the uh
questions that we had since last time
see if we can answer any of them
fellow says uh can you explain the
mystery of why bicycles don't fall over
mathematicians are still stumped by this
question
yeah and he's uh right if you look it up
you'll find that uh they try to figure
out why
when a bicycle stands still it just
falls over
and if you're on the bike unless you you
know move a little bit unless you if you
stand completely still you're going to
fall over
but when you're writing it you don't
fall over
and so the question is why
well there's there's a lot of variables
that they looked at over there and
people who investigate these things and
i can only urge you to look at a video
that
that's out there
talking about this the only uh factor
i'm going to add to that is gravity mass
and gravity okay they've got other
issues there like friction of the wheel
on the ground et cetera et cetera okay
they've got other variables there i'm
just going to concentrate on mass and
and um
and gravity
and what i got to say about that is the
following here you see
uh the lady and she's turning around and
for some reason you know she doesn't
fall on the floor right
and we know that when a skater or
someone like that you know twirls around
in place
um
they they they can uh they can throw
around for almost forever like if you
know what's pulling on them like they
can open their arms and it's like
someone's pulling on their arms and the
question is what is pulling on their
arms
and the answer is uh was given first
in general terms by a fellow named mach
known as mach's principal einstein used
that
as a uh
foundation for his theory as well
and max said that you know when you pull
you're essentially pulling against the
stars
and that's about all he said about it
because he knew nothing more than that
he could not add anything to that
it's not until now that we have a
different proposal we say that all atoms
in the universe are physically
interconnected they're all
interconnected by elect what we call
electromagnetic ropes again it looks
like any ordinary rope okay
and it binds any two atoms and so when
you turn around right
you're pulling
essentially you're dragging against the
entire universe
you're dragging against every atom in
the universe because every atom in the
universe is tied to every atom in your
body
okay so that's
what gravity and mass is mass is the in
that sense the opposite of gravity right
gravity pulls you up mass is what causes
the resistance what is the resistance
gravity is pulling against all the atoms
in the universe okay
but they're so far away that fortunately
you know uh gravity works as a function
of of distance of the
inverse
of distance
so all i can do is tell you that um what
they say in those videos where they talk
about the bicycle falling over
i pretty much agree with most of what
they say there you can just watch the
videos and you can find them relatively
easy on youtube and the only thing i'm
going to add is the
uh
underlying cause of gravity and mass and
that has to do with the fact that all
atoms aren't physically interconnected
okay another question issue fellow says
i lost it
give me a second here on the other side
uh says molecular structure atomic bond
or structure of the m has not been
changed in the glass
this has to do with a one-way mirror
issue yeah hello insists this is like
the fourth time
uh
uh he is doing everything possible to
elude the question so he continues to
raise um
strawman okay
uh i've already told him and said it
just a couple times now that it has
nothing to do with molecular structure
you're beating uh a straw man there okay
we're talking about atoms
one atom not even atoms because that's
too complicated for some people
obviously talking about one atom that
constitutes or is a
component of
that mirror one-way mirror okay you got
mirror from one end and you got glass
from the other end from one end you can
see
and the guy on the other side the gal
can see the guy but the guy can only see
himself in the mirror okay
and so what we do we replace those two
people
okay and we're gonna put two lasers
okay maybe what is it the red laser
maybe 620 nanometers thereabouts
so we point one laser at the glass
and uh it goes uh
yeah
we point at the mirror
and we can see that there's a reflection
the
the
laser
went through because the the person on
the other side the gal in this case
right she would see the laser
okay
and the guy also sees his own laser but
he doesn't see what's on the other side
of the mirror
so
we're looking at only the photons that
make up the laser
only the photons that make up the laser
it doesn't matter the
glass is coated it doesn't matter if
there's lighting in the room none of
that matters the question here is why
does light go
in one direction
okay
and not in the other when you point the
laser in the other direction it hits
it's like if it hits a brick wall
okay we're only talking about the laser
photons
and why do we raise that issue well for
this you got to
understand what quantum says the
question has to do with quantum not with
the mirror or not with the one-way
mirror or anything
or the lighting in the room or anything
like that it's got to do with the
explanation that quantum mechanics gives
to why something is transparent or
opaque okay
and so what does quantum say okay we
gotta understand what quantum says to
answer the question the question is not
anything related to molecular structure
so don't talk about molecular structure
again it has to do with this with the
fact that under quantum mechanics
okay under quantum mechanics a photon
knocks an electron in
if if the electron absorbs that photon
it jumps to a higher energy level
if it does so if it absorbs the photon
the photon does not reach your eye and
the material to which that electron
belongs is opaque
on the other hand if the uh
the photon does not have enough energy
to knock that electron to a higher
energy level
it either is absorbed and speeded out
again or it doesn't even get absorbed at
all and it goes through and in that case
the material is said to be transparent
this is the question so don't change the
question the question is why
does
the
laser light get absorbed in one
direction and not in the other direction
and here we see again what we're talking
about give me a second here
let me get this out of here
okay this is the question the question
is here we have the uh
photon okay from one side and from the
other
okay and these are laser photons we're
only going to talk about one photon
we're only going to talk about one atom
one atom belongs to
the glass
to the one-way mirror anywhere you want
to put it you want to put in the uh you
want to put that float at that uh atom
as part of the coating do it you want to
do it as part of the glass whatever you
want i don't get put anywhere in that
mirror
the issue here is why according to
quantum mechanics why
the photon is absorbed in one direction
in this case from the right
and it goes through in the other
direction
why doesn't the why does it why does the
uh atom there
choose the direction in which it's
coming why does it absorb one photon and
not the other photon
that's the question okay so don't talk
about molecular structure don't talk
about coding don't talk about lighting
in the room none of that has to do
anything with the question that's being
asked the question is
why doesn't one atom
absorb
one photon and it does absorb the other
that's the only issue
okay you got the question
okay uh because if you don't answer the
question then you don't know the answer
period and just admit it
instead of fooling around twiddling uh
you know with nonsense that nobody asks
i mean this is what the four fifth time
now
okay uh false
dictionary definition of scientific
method scientific method a method of
procedure that has characterized natural
science since the 17th century
consisting of
observation measurement experiment
formulation
testing and modification of hypothesis
okay
so what have we achieved with this
so-called scientific method we call it
the mathematical method really the
mathematical method because it ended up
with these kinds of results
uh what do we have we have a corpuscle
can be at two places at once that's what
quantum says concept zero d singularity
twill stars twirls stars around that's
what general relativity says
the vacuum was created at the big bang
another
mantra from general relativity you can
travel forward in time whatever that is
and kill your great grandson
huh is that true
okay
a mathematical concept called dark
matter holds stars together in a galaxy
that's what keeps the galaxy from
breaking apart according to these people
it's called it's a concept called dark
matter they're looking for it now
light is both a particle and a wave also
known as a wave packet see if you can
imagine that
electrons are point corpuscles that
orbit a nucleus without anything binding
them to it so we have this electron
going around
a nucleus and nothing ties it to the
nucleus to the proton for example
so why does it fall into the proton why
does it leave the atom all together
spontaneously
see electrons just whiz around for no
reason and nothing binds them to to this
proton
and then gravity is the warping of time
so
that's what this so-called scientific
method produced after 400 years
so i think we have to say that this
mathematical method
is irrational that's what it is it
doesn't produce any rational
explanations for how the universe works
that's the point so yeah
it makes no sense for people just to
copy
and paste what they saw out there
they need to criticize it
they need to find out if that so-called
scientific method has any validity
whatsoever
and no you cannot say well everybody
uses this method this is what i was
taught in high school in college and uh
we all agreed to it and
you know this is not science is not
about democracy there is no democracy in
science the way it works is you got to
get inside the ring and fight for your
definition and if you're going to defend
that definition well hopefully you can
answer those questions is are those the
results that that mathematical method
produced
is that what we are supposed to believe
are those the uh explanations we should
have have for how father universe runs
his his shop
okay so that's what you got to think
about
okay uh here we have another fella he
says well how does single row split into
three by passing through the prism
that's what made me laugh
poor fellow he thinks that's a single
rope
no white light is made out of gazillions
of ropes gazillions you know with
gazillions let me put a billion ropes so
that you make it maybe are able to look
up the word billion okay billion is good
enough for you
it's made out of a lot of ropes
okay
so we have a lot of ropes
coming
into one atom
and that atom is connected by robes to
other atoms inside the prism
and one rope goes this way the other one
goes that way the other one goes the
other way okay so it's that one rope
breaking into three and coming out into
three what you have is with many ropes
coming in to many ropes
and coming out as many ropes what
changes is the so-called frequency
wavelength in other words what we're
changing is the length of the link and
the number of links that's all that's
happening okay but you can't you can't
simulate that with either particles or
waves as you see on the top part there
okay you can't do that with either
particles or waves
okay and now there is no difference in
speed
light always travels at the same speed
between any two atoms because it doesn't
travel at all it just torques in place
so what we're looking at is only uh
according to the equation there c equals
frequency times wavelength frequency
goes up wavelength goes down and vice
versa so they're inversely proportional
very simple that's the equation overall
straightforward okay but if you've got
something else to model that equation
with which is an amply proven equation
that the velocity of light is a product
of frequency times wavelength well if
you got something better than a rope
be my guest
i want to see how you can show with
whatever other object that you have out
there that when you increase the
frequency wavelength will necessarily go
down to maintain the constancy of the
speed of light in a vacuum
i'm saying it it's always the same speed
but at least in a vacuum it's already
been certified okay so in a vacuum do it
with any other object increase the
frequency and show me why what causes
physically causes the wavelength to go
down and vice versa
only a row can do that
uh here we have another fellow he says a
single rope torques an atom expands its
electron shell and the atom torques back
all ropes connected to it no yeah okay
then how can you have such things as
lasers and other confined beams
disregarding dispersion
oh my god you know those blinders that
they have for the horses we should put
them on him okay here you have a laser
pointer
okay
now what do you think would happen if i
took the wrapping
from the laser in other words all this
metal stuff that covered this is a metal
covering for the laser mechanism inside
what do you think i took that out what
do you think would happen to the laser
would it continue still running just as
a single line in that direction to
towards my right in this case
or would it go in every direction
what do you think would happen
you know in fact when you point the
laser at the wall it doesn't really it
makes a little point but you see some
dispersion there okay what is that
dispersion why is it dispersing
shouldn't it always go straight um you
know only forward
you know uh i worked in the industry in
the semiconductor industry for a while
and i ran an operation known as
an implanter a
implantation
and it's a small accelerator that's all
it is it's a
accelerator of ions you essentially
ionize some material and now you can
manipulate it with magnets run it down
the beam line and hit and force that
thing to go into a wafer typically
phosphorus or boron okay so the question
is
why doesn't that
phosphorus that original source go in
every direction why doesn't the boron go
in every direction
the answer is it does
and you have to put the blinders on it
you know
to focus it to to take it in a given
direction without those blinders you
know
it'll go in every direction it'll go uh
radially
so you have to
you know
orient it you got to say you got to go
this way and the way you do that is with
magnets
okay so there is a way of putting
blinders on uh gases
and the way it's done again is with
these um
with these magnets
and that's more or less what's happening
here you know
the beam here would go in every
direction if it weren't for the fact
that it's channeled
uh in a given direction
that's one issue a more important is
your more basic issue you can't talk and
i already mentioned this this guy
apparently missed it you can't talk
about one rope
doing
um
in one atom doing laser
a laser is made of gazillions of ropes
uh did i say that right gazillions you
don't know what gazillion is just take
billions as as a number or how about
many is that good enough you need many
ropes many atoms to produce a laser you
can't do it with one so you can't
put the laser question in terms of one
atom one rope
okay
i don't know if that sunk but i i give
it my best shot there
okay and final question here or the
issue fellow says why are you showing
experiments
at the beginning and 24 37 huh
i thought you guys didn't do experiments
over here
well uh the way it works is that you
know uh i point to the moon and the guy
stairs at my finger and i say no no you
gotta look at the moon don't look at my
finger
we don't do experiments
we don't do experiments in science okay
so but you did an experiment i did an
experiment yes i did an experiment was
that the scientific part no that's not
the scientific part
that's only people who have been
raised on this mathematical method
they do they do uh experiments they do
experiment don't understand anything
they cannot explain anything but they
did experiments oh i did experiments i i
mixed the red liquid with a with a
uh blue liquid and what happened well it
went kaboom when i went to the hospital
oh great and when did you learn i
shouldn't do it again
so no we don't do experiments what we're
doing with all those
experiments
as you call them right
i was trying to get through your thick
skull
all the possibilities you have to
consider
to be able to what explain
uh opacity and transparency all the
things that affect transparency and
opacity so we were looking at different
aspects of all the variables you have to
take into consideration if you're going
to explain why glass why water why uh
air are transparent and why a brick wall
is not
so it's not the experiment you got to
focus on
you got to focus on
the mechanisms that mother nature uses
to do opacity and transparency
got it
okay with that we'll see you what on
sunday